c'est ici dans le plus grand centre de
recherche de la route mondiale à magny
les hameaux que le groupe colas imagine
les routes de demain dernière innovation
en date la route ou à tous et elle
permet de capter l'énergie électrique
avec les rayons du soleil
c'est une grande révolution parce que ça
permet d'avoir un autre usage à la route
pas uniquement un usage de mobilité mais
également un usage de production
d'énergie et de produire de l'énergie
renouvelable verte sur sur nos routes
cinq ans de recherches ont été
nécessaires pour élaborer cette route
solaire elle permet de recharger les
voitures électriques ou d'apporter un
complément d'électricité pour les
maisons par exemple avec un kilomètre de
route
équipé de daloa tout et on peut
approvisionner l'éclairage public d'une
ville de 5000 habitants
c'est certainement un des avenirs 1 d
avenir de la consommation d'énergie bien
sur l'énergie verte locale la beauté de
ce dispositif c'est qu'on produit
l'énergie là où on la consomme le big
data de la route est aussi l'un des
grands axes d'innovation du groupe
comment avoir un usage plus simple de la
route peut être avec ce capteurs
intelligents implanté dans la chaussée
colas a effectivement développé un
capteur un capteur qui s'installe dans
la chaussette qui autonome en énergie
qui permet d'être facilement installé à
l'intérieur d'une chaussée et qui permet
de remonter des informations sûres
des places disponibles pour le parking
mais également de trafic si le groupe
colas représentent 57 mille
collaborateurs aujourd'hui à travers le
monde
c'est sur le site de magny les hameaux
que l'innovation est en développement
avec plus de 2000 chercheurs dédiés